jocko do you believe in overtraining do
you believe in overtraining
or is that an excuse people use you have
the ct fletcher's triathletes yourself
etc who get after it daily
you also find other elite athletes who
believe in rest days who are by no means
slackers
what's your take you know what can you
over train yes you can
yeah you can definitely over train i
will say this most people
don't over train because you got to work
pretty hard to overtrain yeah
and if you over train you'll know it if
you're paying attention to your
performance because your performance
will start to go down
that that's what's happening and i've
said this before i've seen it with
fighters
that were preparing for a fight and
they'd be over training and you'd watch
their performance
someone that's normally crushing let's
say the fighters normally crushing
training partner a and all of a sudden
training a partner a starts getting the
better of the fighter
and you know you know it's it's obvious
the guy's over trained so take a couple
days off
get some steak and get get back
get get reset because you're over
trained so yeah you can overtrain for
sure
now what i don't believe in well it's
hard to overtrain
i mean these guys are working hard when
they're over training
but a lot of people just they they do
you can use overtraining as an excuse
what i do is
i'm going to do something every day i
try and do something every day
regardless like even if even if i feel
like i'm complete like last night i got
kind of beat up on the map
i know i'm pretty i'm pretty over
trained right now
but i'm also getting ready to go on a
trip so i'm like okay well i just gonna
still
i squatted today and i'm still gonna
train hard tonight and then i got a
couple days where i'll be on the road
uh i might take one of those days and
just like do more of a stretch
mobility type scenario work i'll still
get the blood flowing because i got to
get the blood flowing god but you know
maybe just like a hundred burpees and
then a bunch of stretching
so i'll do a little recovery on the road
but yes you can over train
it's hard to do it if your performance
is going down you're over training
eat some steak take a break take a break
eat some steak take over
eats bro 100 burpees kind of a lot
i think 100 burpees yeah you know it's
like there's
less than 10 minutes put it this way i
did oh then again all the time they did
100 burpees with after workout so dennis
feels a little different
yeah you just go do 100 burpees
yeah well the okay so over training
though is like there's two or maybe even
more
different kinds of quote unquote over
training so there's like
there's like a for real like i don't
know for
i'm gonna misuse it a clinical
version of over training which is like
official like your blood
you can recognize it in your blood and
like certain things and certain whatever
and there's all these symptoms
they're not a spot it's a thing it's an
actual thing like you don't sleep
and it's like your body essentially goes
into this like negative kind of feedback
or positive feedback loop where it's
like but just
you're over training and it takes like a
while to get out of it like a while you
got to go through
this process and then there's also like
a condition
like rhabdo something yeah that's a
serious
situation yeah that's essentially over
training yes that's
acute over training quickly
yeah yeah usually to get hit with the
rabbit yeah and then there's like this
kind of
gray area and you can get rhabdo i guess
you can get i think
i think you get rhabdo in like certain
muscle groups
but anyways rhabdo yeah that'll take you
out i remember cake nuts was
we're rolling cake nuts he's the kind
guy who's like just kind of down for
anything not just kind of like
fire plug type guy because he's super
mellow but he's just down for anything
like the kind where if you're going to
go do something kind of weird
he'll or whatever he'll always sort of
just be there
you know he always kind of says yes so
anyway we're training and
he you know when someone asks you to
roll and you're done you're like oh no
done maybe next time you know not cake
nuts no
he was like he was like okay he does and
you could tell he was like tired he's
like okay and then we're all done
already and then you know how certain
guys come in later whatever maybe one
two guys
and another guy asked him to run we're
like dang cake that's still rolling and
i think he even rolled before us
too and he was just rolling around he
might have did some other pt or whatever
and he's like man he's like man
i'm i'm pretty tired right now and then
another guy asked him well let's roll
and he's like okay
and we're just laughing like it was kind
of a white belt yeah which means all
these
which means all these roles are not like
yeah relaxed scenarios they're actual
level nine death battles yeah he's going
for it yeah he's a purple
by the way oh that's cool yeah um but
yeah at the time i think he was white
belt and
yeah so he goes and he's like man i'm
tired i messed up and i was like yeah
man i dig it and you rolled a lot
and sure and come to find out he had rap
though yeah but anyway
go and then there's a gray area over
training where
you're training a lot maybe your
testosterone will be down from training
a lot
and me you know your nutrition may or
may not be all that kind of thing so
your performance does go down
you feel a little bit more tired going
into training you know if you're lifting
or whatever you can't lift this heavy
and all this stuff that's like a great
or you're not over trained though
you just how you say just eat a steak
and a day two days later
boom you're kind of back in the game you
know kind of thing but i don't think
that's a clinical
technically over trained maybe you're
not recovering day to day as much or
something like this but
nonetheless but all true things all real
things hey your body's this machine man
if you you know with all these different
systems that the systems ain't work all
ain't working right you may not get you
know the performance that you uh
that you want